So some Comments on Postconditions. First of all, we've only been concerned so
far with pure functions. And a pure function is one in which the output
is completely determined by the input. However, in real programming languages,
computational units like functions, procedures and methods may be impure. For
impure functions, in addition to describing how the output relates to
the input you should also indicate any side effect. These include changes to
global variables and any operations like input and output that
aren't reflected in the results of the function. And if we're talking about and
OO. That is, an object oriented programming language, then changes to any
instance variables of the of, of the object that we're dealing with,
are also things that we would have to express inside the post conditions. But so
far, with square root we don't have to worry about that.
And it's also the cates that, that sort is going to be a pure function, so
we don't have to worry about it there.